and finally new rule now that trump's
poll numbers are falling like a rock
democrats must realize that the way to
get his voters back
is through graciousness
yeah a rare opportunity is presenting
itself these days for america to return
to the more normal time before we had
trump because finally there are signs
the trump fever is starting to break
attendance is down at his rallies and
his press release brain farts don't make
news like they once did with the tweets
when he braves for attention now it
feels like madonna singing [ __ ] i'm
madonna
[Applause]
if you uh if you have to say it maybe
you ain't it anymore
and
look at these recent poll numbers in
october 2020 54 of republicans said they
were more loyal to trump than the party
and only 38 percent chose the party over
trump well now those numbers have
essentially flipped
okay this can't all be coming from the
raw animal magnetism of mitch mcconnell
[Applause]
trump has fallen
26 points among white republicans
without a college degree down 21 among
conservative republicans 18 among
republican men 23
among republicans over 65
down 19 among white evangelicals okay
that is a description of the very people
who made him a star in politics men
people over 65 jesus freaks and white
guys who didn't go to college
but more and more even the poorly
educated are looking at trump the way
leah remini looked at scientology
with the mixture of anger and what the
[ __ ] was i thinking
[Applause]
even the q anon shaman is now saying he
was duped by trump
the outfit he has to own that himself
two-thirds of republicans now even
approve of mike pence certifying the
electoral votes which is why it's so
important that we heard someone like
nancy pelosi stating unequivocally that
the january 6th capital riot was a
violent insurrection for the purpose of
trying to prevent the peaceful transfer
of power after a legitimately certified
election
wait nancy pelosi didn't say that
mitch mcconnell said that
it was a violent insurrection
[Applause]
for the purpose of trying to prevent the
peaceful transfer of power
after a legitimately certified election
and mike pence said
president trump is wrong
i had no right to overturn the election
okay something must be shifting if
gutless wonders like pence and mcconnell
[Applause]
are daring to say out loud finally that
the emperor has no clue
barack obama was once asked in an
interview by jerry seinfeld what sport
is politics most like and obama
said football
because there's a lot of hitting a lot
of attrition you have to punt a lot but
once in a while
a hole opens up in the line and you have
an opportunity to run through it and
gain ground
this is that opportunity
this is that hole in the line opening up
the question now really is for democrats
how are you going to handle that
trump's bond with his supporters is
hatred for people they think look down
on them
now that these supporters are wavering
let's not nudge them back into trump's
embrace by showing no graciousness
[Applause]
the democrats own committee responsible
for getting democrats elected this
november is telling their candidates you
are losing because you come off as
preachy and judgmental so sure the
temptation will be to humiliate
republican voters who are now finally
coming to their senses about trump to
shame them call them deplorable and say
what were you thinking you stupid [ __ ]
i'm saying don't do that don't jump
don't you
i know it's i made it sound good but
don't do it
don't do that that will drive them right
back into trump's arms look we've all
had a friend who's dated a psycho
and when they come to their senses the
last thing they want to talk about is
how they dated a psycho
it took trump voters a long time to make
it all the way down the maga rabbit hole
to jump on them the second they poked
their head out
would ensure many more years of
political winter
instead of saying
nice work you stupid racist [ __ ] kicker
maybe try
hey how you been
welcome back to the wonderful world of
reality
[Applause]
you got taken by a salesman happens to
all of us
and
don't and don't talk politics at all
just say i don't know uh how about that
yellowstone show huh
little things little things that'll make
them think hey maybe democrats don't all
eat babies
[Laughter]
provide a face-saving path for them to
become traditional indoor republicans
again
like the greatest republican of all
abraham lincoln did when he said after
the civil war with malice toward none
with charity for all when lincoln
when lincoln defeated the south he
didn't dance on their graves
when he visited the front lines near the
end of the war he comforted the wounded
on both sides he didn't humiliate them
he told his generals let them go home
let them have their horses to plow with
and their guns to shoot crows lincoln's
approach
was the one truman adopted after world
war ii and today germany and japan are
peaceful prosperous allies
similar policies were instituted in
south africa after apartheid in rwanda
after the genocide there it is a lesson
woodrow wilson forgot at the end of
world war one when the allies chose to
humiliate germany and gave the world
hitler
it's a lesson that perhaps america
forgot when the soviet union fell and we
continued to treat russia as an enemy to
be contained and not a new friend to be
welcomed in
[Applause]
in
japan after world war ii we staged
wrestling matches between japanese and
american wrestlers and we made sure to
sometimes make the american the bad guy
which was a huge morale boost to the
japanese people and in fact made the
matches so popular they almost
single-handedly jump-started japan's
television industry which led them to
becoming the
economic powerhouse they are today so
even though we dropped nuclear bombs on
them somehow much was forgotten simply
by letting their wrestler kick our
wrestler in the nuts
[Applause]
we need hugs not smugs
and if that means having to swallow the
impulse to say i told you so and take a
couple of fake kicks to the groin well
then i regret that i have but two nuts
to give for my country
you